hacia fort estará con nosotros profesor
hasta dónde podría llegar la batalla
legal del presidente
luego de impugnar estas elecciones en
varios estados
bueno gracias por la invitación todo
todo aparenta que el equipo republicano
del párking en torno a trump ha
preparado equipos legales para hacer
durar mucho una batalla legal después de
que ha fallado la autoproclamación como
presidente dándose en la primera noche
el como vencedor es importante lo que
pasa en nevada pero es importante
también el clima de inestabilidad que se
está generando en todo el país
ahora bien trump ha convertido a eeuu en
el epicentro de la pandemia ha
demostrado ser lo suficientemente
irresponsable como para arrastrar a su
país a la inestabilidad fruto de un
largo proceso legal habida cuenta de que
él ha nombrado a varios magistrados del
alto tribunal de los eeuu una situación
bien compleja no tenga la menor duda así
de jose antonio ahora el presidente
donald trump ha dicho en varias
oportunidades y lo sigue diciendo que
hubo fraude electoral le preguntó bajo
qué pruebas porque hasta ahora nadie
claro yo no he respondido yo eso sí no
los actores políticos norteamericanos
que dicen cómo es posible que hable de
fraude sin presentar una sola prueba lo
que estamos viendo aquí es una
repetición del síndrome why do que trump
el intento en venezuela ahora él está
intentando hacer lo mismo al menos en
este caso sí es verdad que se ha
presentado a unas elecciones
presidenciales lo que no en el caso
tengo ha ido pero ambos resultados ambas
ambos no ven métodos no van a dar un
buen resultado porque en votos numéricos
biden habla de 70 millones eso está
bastante computado aunque hay que
reconocer que trump tiene 68 millones de
votos aunque ya sabemos que lo que
cuenta son los colegios electorales algo
que no entiende nadie en el mundo porque
solamente funcionan los estados unidos
de norteamérica y es quien puede ganar
las elecciones aún perdiendo el número
de votos directos de cada ciudadano en
francia no pasa si en américa latina
tampoco así es josé antonio pero
entonces en ese contexto
a pedir que se pare este conteo de los
votos no estaría desconociendo los casi
100 millones de votos que han llegado
por correo el voto anticipado entonces
ese es otro asunto el número de votos
por correo que son masivos yo creo que
hay que reconocer que trump ha cometido
un gran número de votos ha tumbado las
encuestas que es un método inventado en
los propios eeuu las encuestas no han
funcionado porque daban diez o veinte
puntos por encima y piden pero queda
efectivamente el número de el número de
papeletas por correo ahora hay un
problema añadido
eeuu no cuenta con una autoridad
electoral fiable que pueda digamos
interponerse entre los intereses de las
dos partes en conflicto de manera que
al parecer va a ser la calle la presión
de la calle la que va a determinar un
poco la capacidad que tiene trump de
resistir a lo que parece ser una
inevitable derrota parece ser